It's tailgate season in America and I'm tired of everyone just ordering burgers on their phone
So I'm putting the challenge out there to Mia to see what she can come up with in just 10 minutes
Mia, don't disappoint. Welcome to "Ramsay in 10".
Hi guys! I'm Mia Castro, I'm the challenge Queen from Hell's Kitchen
Today Gordon challenged me to make a burger in under 10 Minutes
so I'm making my version of a
Tailgate turkey burger with an avocado spread and I'm adding some potato sticks for a little bit of crunch too
So like any good football competition, Gordon you're on. Let's start
So right here
I have some ground turkey
What I like to add to turkey burger is because sometimes they end up being on the dry side is some zucchini
To keep them moist and I'm just gonna grate it right into here
And if you don't have one of these at home
You can just use a box grater or kind of just like rough chop it yourself
And I have some pre-chopped garlic
I have some smoked paprika and I like using this because
It gives food that sort of like ham or bacon flavor
We're gonna try to add as much flavor as we can into the meat
Everyone needs to chill out on measuring
I just I throw things in there and you can just taste it as you go take a little piece of burger
Throw it on the grill, taste it, if it needs more, add more
some salt
pepper
Stir that up
And if you're having people over for game day, you can just make these patties ahead of time
So when you have your guests over all you have to do is throw them on the grill or on the pan
We don't really watch that much football in Puerto Rico
At least my family didn't, but for any game day like if it's a boxing match or for us
It's actually the Miss Universe pageant
Then I'm gonna pre-boil the pan real quick because I'm about to use my hands
to form these patties
So the thinner the patty the faster its gonna cook it's really up to you
how thick you want it. I'm trying to prove Gordon right though. So I want to finish this in 10 minutes
Then right on the pan
When you get the burger on you want to make sure that your heat is on medium-high
I like it when it gets kind of crispy around it. And that's why I actually prefer turkey burgers to beef burgers
You want a list of ingredients - just check the description below. While that's cooking, I'm gonna make a quick sauce with avocados
And this is a good substitution for mayonnaise and cheese. That way you don't feel like crap after you eat a burger
Sorry this pit is
Not cooperating
If the pit's not cooperating just take it out with a fork
But these knives are so sharp. They're cutting through the pit
Gordon do you actually even use your knives here? They're so sharp
All right, whatever.
We're still good! I got this, Gordon
So just a little bit of salt, some lemon juice
This is something else that you can pre make ahead of time and a little bit of olive oil
Then just mash it up with a fork
Alright, so don't forget your burger. I'm gonna oil it on top again a little bit so it gets nice and brown on the other side
We're gonna toast our patty
So, get a little bit of butter on there. So it gets a really good golden brown color.
I actually like to season the buns a little bit so you actually taste the butter
Straight down, I think we're gonna make it, Gordon. One nice slice of tomato
And you can top it with whatever you want, these are just my favorite things
Flatten it
Check your buns, don't burn them.
Oh, so I'm getting the lettuce flat so it covers
The bun really nice and I get two pieces on there. I like to put it in the bottom
so that the juice from the turkey burger doesn't
Make the bun soggy
going with
Turkey right on top
So, you know if it's done by kind of poking it in the middle and if it feels firm, it's ready to go
Let's check our bun
Perfect
I like to season my tomato.
A little olive oil as well.
It's getting really close now these avocados could have ruined me. I think they still have it though.
Magic touch..."papitas" (potatoes in spanish) get a lot of them on there. That's what makes it really good
And time is ticking so I got to get this on
There we go.
Oh my God, I think that was just ten minutes. Gordon, you almost had me but there you go. Tailgate turkey burgers in ten minutes
Gracias por sintonizar a Ramsay in 10
Dejame un comentario abajo
con lo que pensaron de la hamburguesa
Y no olviden suscribirse al canal de chef Gordon Ramsay en YouTube
For those of you that didn't catch that
Thank you for watching "Ramsay in ten". Don't forget to subscribe to Gordon's YouTube channel and leave a comment below!
Gracias!